what is going on everybody welcome back
to the cosmic wonder I'm Warren Thompson
and we have been treated very well
recently when it comes to Deadpool 3 we
got our first look at Hugh Jackman as
Wolverine returning after so many years
in the classic yellow Wolverine suit
from the comics we got some footage of
Wolverine and Deadpool fighting which
seemingly reveals that they are actually
going to be fighting in the void which
was shown to us around the end of Loki's
season 1. all the info we've been
getting about Deadpool 3 recently has
been fantastic and a lot of characters
have been reported and rumored to be
making Cameo appearances in Deadpool 3.
so in this video today we're going to
put them all in one spot and talk about
all of the characters that could
possibly show up in Deadpool 3 that have
been rumored and reported to be in the
film and a lot of these cameos are super
exciting ranging from the old foxman
characters to some characters that are
from the MCU coming into this universe
with Deadpool and Wolverine so let's go
down all of these characters and if
you're new and you want to stay up to
date on the MCU be sure to subscribe to
the channel so you don't miss out on any
of the latest news and so you can enter
our giveaway for a chance to win an Xbox
series X A PS5 some Marvel Legends items
or some DC items the winner gets to pick
one item and we pick a winner at the end
of each month just subscribe and leave a
comment so so far there have been over
15 reported cameos that are going to
appear in Deadpool 3. now we'll first
start off by addressing that this is
different than Multiverse of Madness in
Multiverse of Madness before the film
came out we were expecting a ton of
different cameos because we really
thought Doctor Strange was going to be
traveling to other universes throughout
basically the entire film that sadly was
not the case but we do know that
Deadpool is going to be going to other
universes in Deadpool 3 and we know that
he's going to kind of be working
alongside the TBA basically doing what
Loki did in season one and thanks to the
set videos and photos that I mentioned
before we already know that Deadpool is
going to be going back to the old Fox
X-Men Universe we have seen the old Fox
logo the old Fox sign in some set photos
and videos so we know that this is true
this is confirmed so we know that he's
going to be seeing some old foxman
characters so our expectations I think
are about right although we shouldn't
expect anything insane like a Galactus
Cameo the cameos that we can expect are
pretty epic now let's start off with
what we basically know already Owen
Wilson he is coming back he's going to
be in Deadpool 3 at least for a moment
he has been spotted on the set of
Deadpool 3. this is confirmed especially
if you consider that he is a huge part
of the TVA and the TVA is going to get
in touch with Deadpool and along with
the TVA it's been reported that the
tva's Minutemen are going to be in the
movie as well doing a forest chase scene
many people have reported about the
forest chase scene but Daniel rpk on his
patreon account is the one that reported
about the Minutemen we assume they're
going to be chasing Deadpool and or
Wolverine but that is not confirmed at
the moment but expect cameos from the
Minutemen who are basically the prime
soldiers of the TVA now to get into some
cameos that are a little bit more juicy
and exciting Sir Patrick Stewart and Sir
Ian McKellen are going to return for
Deadpool 3. this is coming from Insider
my time to shine hello now one big thing
that you need to know that you might
have heard before especially if you
follow the channel is that Deadpool is
rumored to be visiting a universe where
the X-Men are in charge Magneto is the
ruler of the earth and the X-Men rule
over the humans and in this universe the
X-Men are a part of Magneto's
Brotherhood so they're all essentially
rulers so Patrick Stewart appearing with
Ian McKellen as Professor Xavier and
Magneto makes sense and is expected
especially if you consider what Patrick
Stewart said not too long ago that him
and Ian McKellen weren't done yet with
their Marvel characters so this is
pretty much confirmed also keep this
story and this universe and mine as we
go through these other cameos we'll come
back to it in a really big way for a
really big fight scene that is going to
take place now we have two other cameos
that are just kind of crazy to hear
about and I know a lot of fans really
can't wait to see one if not both of
these cameos and that is Ben Affleck
returning as Daredevil in Deadpool 3.
this has been reported on by Casey Walsh
and many other insiders as well Ben
Affleck has also been reportedly seen on
set again Deadpool is set to visit other
previous Marvel universes that aren't
the MCU visiting older Marvel characters
so it's possible that he does visit the
universe that Daredevil took place in or
perhaps they combined that Universe with
the X-Men universe but along with Ben
Affleck's Daredevil is coming Jennifer
Gardner's Elektra and this has been
confirmed by many insiders but also The
Hollywood Reporter a major Outlet so
this one is confirmed and this basically
confirms that Ben Affleck is returning
as well especially since he's been seen
on set now of course the two of them
were in the 2003 Daredevil film so both
of them coming back makes perfect sense
then we have a really really cool one
and quite satisfying and that is
Channing Tatum as Gambit now Channing
Tatum was supposed to play Gambit in his
own solo Gambit movie unfortunately that
never happened and Channing Tatum
expressed that he was really bummed out
about that but it looks like Ryan
Reynolds is gonna give him that
opportunity that he never got a chance
to be a Marvel Superhero a chance to do
kind of the role that he wanted to do
Gambit this report is coming from
Insider my time to shine hello and this
is one of my favorite cameos that has
been reported or rumored because one I
love Gambit I love the character too I
think Channing Tatum would make a really
good gamut and three I'm glad that he is
finally getting this opportunity because
he has verbally expressed that it was
really bummed out before now the next
one is really cool dog pool and this is
coming from The Insider can we get some
toast I cannot wait to see dogpool in
Deadpool 3. Now dog pool was owned by
mascara X and they experimented on
dogpool testing their numerous products
and particularly their new Cosmetics due
to these experiments he mutated and
began to get the power to heal himself
mascara X thought they killed him and
threw him away but of course he healed
he then joined the circus where he would
do a lot of really great stunts until
Deadpool from Earth 616 came and
recruited him for the Deadpool Corps and
speaking of the Deadpool core they are
supposed to appear in this film as well
and that report is coming from Alex P
over at the cosmic circus we're not 100
sure who was going to be a part of the
Deadpool Corps although Lady Deadpool
has been heavily rumored and knowing
Ryan Reynolds the fact that he gets to
have Deadpool variants be a part of this
film Lady Deadpool would definitely be
one that he would love to have you can
just imagine the banter between Deadpool
and Lady Deadpool on screen plus not to
mention the inappropriate but hilarious
jokes that he'll make about there being
a female version of himself now another
Cameo that is said to be appearing
involves both Deadpool and Wolverine and
that is the return of Brian Cox as
William Striker William Striker played
such a big part of Deadpool and
Wolverine that this comes as little to
no surprise that he could possibly be
appearing in this movie especially if
Deadpool is going back in time and
changing some events that happened it
would make sense that we would run into
him now we're getting into some really
big ones both Casey Walsh and Alex P
from the cosmic circus have reported
that the Illuminati are going to be in
this movie now they haven't specifically
reported that the same Illuminati from
the a38 universe are going to be in this
film but what has been reported is that
Wanda from the 838 universe is going to
be in the film now the Illuminati from
the 838 Universe are dead the Scarlet
Witch killed them by dream walking into
Wanda's a38 body however keep in mind
this isn't just a universe jumping film
but it is also a time travel film and
yes there is a difference you can time
travel back and forth on one timeline or
you can go to a different timeline a
different universe and time travel on
that as well I am really curious to see
how Deadpool and the movie itself
explains time travel and Universal
travel but it is possible that Deadpool
goes to the A3 Universe before the
Scarlet Witch kills all of them or this
could be a completely new Illuminati
team with different characters and
different actors is playing those
characters we won't speculate too much
right now but they are reportedly going
to be in the film now here's where it
gets pretty cool some of the original
X-Men of course are going to be
returning we have reports that Ali Barry
is returning a storm bombka Jensen is
going to be returning as Jean Gray AKA
The Phoenix and James Marsden returning
as Cyclops this is coming from can we
get some toast and also Alex P reports
that Nightcrawler is going to be in the
film as well now it's going to be super
cool to see these original X-Men but one
thing that is extremely cool that has
recently been reported by Alex P at the
cosmic circus is that we are going to
see bamke Jensen's Jean Gray slash the
Phoenix fight Wanda a variant of Wanda
which is most likely the 838 version
since that's the Wanda that is
reportedly going to be in the movie so
going back to the universe ruled by the
X-Men a rumor that is a part of that is
that the X-Men have actually defeated
the Avengers in that universe so if
Wanda is a part of the Avengers we could
see her go to battle again against the
X-Men and Jean Gray take on Wanda as a
part of that fight we don't know the
specific details yet but that could
possibly be what happens what we know
right now is that Alex B is reporting
that two of them are going to fight in
this movie and I am personally super
excited for that now as a little cherry
on top it has been reported that the
original Fantastic Four could possibly
appear as well with Chris Evans being
one that is heavily hinted at by Alex P
and this could honestly be a perfect
Cameo because one Not only would it be
extremely cool to see Chris Evans return
as the Human Torch but you know Deadpool
is gonna say something about Chris Evans
playing both the Human Torch and Captain
America honestly if this doesn't happen
it's gonna be a really big missed
opportunity and Chris Evans has already
done a little Cameo for a Ryan Reynolds
movie before in free guy when they did a
little Marvel callback and they showed
Chris Evans as himself and Chris Evans
has already stated that he's hesitant to
return as Captain America but would like
to return as the Human Torch he said he
thinks that would be cool so I am
expecting that Cameo that pretty much
does it for all the cameos that we've
heard now we have heard that doctor
strange is not going to be involved with
this film which is interesting but we
can probably assume that he's busy doing
whatever with CLIA fixing an incursion
we saw from the post-credit scene of
Multiverse of Madness she came and
grabbed him and said hey you caused an
incursion now it's time to fix it and
they both seemingly went to do that and
this is probably taking place around the
same time that Deadpool 3 is going to
take place so we assume he's busy doing
that I'm personally really excited to
see all of these cameos even if only a
quarter of them show up it's going to be
pretty great but let me know who you are
most excited to see in the comments down
below and don't forget to like the video
and subscribe so you can stay up to date
on the MCU and enter our giveaway you
can also support us further on patreon
you can check out our website and our
Discord server and you can always follow
us on Instagram and Twitter as always
thank you all so much for watching wolf
wolf
please